women I believe
can sense a bad dude like that they can
feel it my mother's amazing at that my
mother I'm telling you has antenna my
mother has saved my dad from going into
business deals really dude
she she can look at a dude and go that
guy's a bad guy I got a bad feeling wow
and that's how women had to survive I
think women can pick up on energy that
we don't because we're not afraid I
don't you know I don't walk around
worrying about my physical safety but
there are women I think women are way
better the the Israelis use women as uh
as bodyguards because they found that if
you take you can teach a woman how to
shoot straight no problem and there's
some badass women so they they found
that women they grow up from the age
about 12 years old they have to be I
wait I see it with my daughter they're
very aware of danger they're very aware
why is that guy over there why is he
looking at me for too long what's going
over here they can just sense these
things